[Musique]
nous défendons les droits des jeunes
filles en luttant contre spécifiquement
le mariage des enfants que nous appelons
communément le mariage précoce luttons
contre les mutilations génitales
féminines les viols sur des mineures
mais nous encourageons aussi
l'émancipation de la jeune fille à
travers son maintien à l'école
[Musique]
mais non aussi des activités redressées
sur le terrain rejoint à la policière
pour faire que pour faire en sorte que
la loire vraiment soit appliquée comme
elle est indiquée dans le code pénal et
le code civil et dans les conventions
que la guinée a ratifié avant notre
naissance
lorsqu'on nous sommes alertés on appelle
la police en descendent sur le terrain
on dit bon voilà aussi la loi qui
interdit cela soit on prend la petite la
jeune fille qui doit être marié parce
que souvent les allaite à laver ou le
jauger du mariage en luttant avec nous à
la maison
et puis après on convoque les parents à
la police
jusqu'aujourd'hui on a pu empêcher plus
le temps car le mariage des enfants si
on le qualifie le viseur de manège on le
fait pour le bien des filles donc il
faut que les gens comprennent ici se
mobilisent briseuse de mariage que
lorsque qu'elle combattait voilà mariage
en forme son pet et nous sommes là pour
briser ce mariage et nous avons pu faire
pour le pisé on ne fait pas illégalement
mais légalement un certain cas précis
nous discours mais d'autres personnes
qui sont vraiment très qui pensent
qu'ils sont conservateurs alors qu'ils
n'ont pas les bonnes informations et qui
se sentent visés par un discours
aujourd'hui nous menace sur le terrain
mais cela ne nous empêche pas de
continuer le combat
7 des fois on nous a même pris en otage
des fois on nous a enfermés dans une
cour on lui dit qu'on ne soit pas
[Musique]
comme toutes ces femmes ou jean-louis
sont mutilés elles seront réduites
est ce que ces femmes ont confiance en m
non il faut se poser cette question
oui que tu sois une vraie femme il faut
compter un but
il faut vraiment qu'on compte réduit est
ce que cette femme en cela qu'elle est
qu'elle pourra apporter quelque chose de
positif à sa communauté
non les autorités doivent être avec nous
parce que il emplit les engagements au
niveau national et au niveau
international et nous on les amène
vraiment à respecter leurs engagements
ce n'est pas qu'une question de la
guinée c'est une question mondiale
si même aux états unis en pratique les
mutilations génitales féminines en
colombie on le fait pas tout dans le
monde le fait
[Musique]
mon rêve c'est d'être avocate les
violences basées sur le genre continuent
encore à sa foi dans nos pays c'est
parce qu'on n'a pas encore une bonne
justice et ça je veux être avocate
reconnue bien défendre les droits des
femmes et des filles comme il le faut il
faut qu'il y ait des femmes qui ont la
passion qui ont l'engagement pour
l'énergie et non l'argent devant pour
mettre fin à ces violences
[Musique]